there's this idea that if they are there
and then Trump gets arrested three more
times and maybe it pulls him off the
campaign Trail they will be able to
swoop in and somehow pick up Trump
supporters by virtue of not having
really attacked Trump at this early
stage is that viable and number two if
it is it can't be viable for all of them
it seems maybe for one of them that
would work it's not viable for any of
them look at the end of the day it's a
position it's rooted in a fundamental
delusional dishonesty put aside their
beliefs their ideology their political
label they're weak and they're afraid
they're terrified of being tweeted about
by Donald Trump